I think to your point uh Beyonce won I
think she just became the most
grammy-winning artist of all time at
this Grammys right Beyonce is one of
those things that like she's one of
these artists that like can do no wrong
and people even if her music is bad even
if she's not interesting even if she's
involved with Scandal even if her
husband or her sister is filmed hitting
her husband in an elevator like she
survives anything she's bulletproof so
to be like and we're bringing back
Beyonce who can who you will rally
around no matter what is sort of this
way to keep an audience that you know
they're not trying to win us over
they're trying to win their base back
over uh and I mean Beyonce won for uh
Renaissance right this is like just
after she performed in um
in the Middle East in a country that's
completely anti-lgbtq even though her
her album is supposed to be based off
the black LGBT experience like it it
doesn't make any sense they don't have
to follow their own rules they just have
to bring out the figureheads that they
like and know that you'll cheer for them
because it's making someone else angry
someone you don't like angry